starting your therapy journey has never
been easier with better health the
sponsors of our next segment check out
how they can help with any of life's
challenges you could be facing
life is full of stressors right it
doesn't matter who you are or what you
do your life is probably a little
stressful you may not be feeling down
and out and depressed or like you're at
a total loss but if your stress levels
are high your temper is shorter than
usual or even if you're starting to feel
strain in any of your relationships
you could probably use a chance to just
unload when there are things you can't
tell anyone or feel like you can't tell
your family and friends you need to
unload it and that's where therapy can
come in better help is the largest
professional therapy platform they offer
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to everything you tell your therapist is
completely confidential betterhelp
employs more than 25 000 therapists who
specialize in specific issues such as
stress anxiety relationships parenting
depression addictions eating sleeping
trauma anger family conflicts lgbt
matters grief religion self-esteem and
so much more it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours there's even a weekly
membership subscription and that
includes one weekly live session and
unlimited messaging and you can also
cancel at any time for any reason unload
the stressors and get some unbiased
feedback you'd be pretty surprised at
what you might gain from it and you know
see if it's for you
thanks to betterhelp for sponsoring this
segment today's viewers get 20 off their
first month at betterhelp.com2022
that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash
22 20 22.